moi qui suis allé vers le rassemblement
national depuis quelques années je
côtoyais 11 et les émissions ensemble on
parlait l'offre le fameux aof après
amélie organise donc s'en remet en cause
quand même très haut ça je suis citoyen
quand même oui mais non mais attends tu
nous dis ça fait quelques années que je
vote et j'ai toujours vos amis sans ces
militants du rassemblement national
j'ai pris ma carte en septembre dernier
et vous avez continué d'être à l'antenne
attendez vous poseriez la même question
à quelqu'un qui a sa carte europe
ecologie les verts et la république et
marché qu'est journalistes et qu'ils
journalisme je reconnais ma alors c'est
vrai que ça a énormément choqué oui non
vous avez des points car d'autres titres
mucci riccione à ce que ça vous dérange
vous avez dit est-ce qu'on peut être
journaliste était engagé bien sûr ça ne
dérange pas et je le suis on sur le rat
mais là il a franchi le rubicon voilà
les journalistes il est passé de l'autre
côté de la barrière
il le dit ils l'assument et quand son
avance sans masque très bien dont acte
après on peut jouer roger après une
marque qui tourne l'attend
on attend ce qui pose question et c'est
ça qui pose problème qu'à une carrière
pendant une dizaine une vingtaine ou une
trentaine d'années donc on peut lui
faire voilà pendant une excavation de
bruit ou pas je comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure combien d'actes exemple
etc et encore claude sérillon et à bruno
roger-petit à leur rang same et ses
terrasses et une en france à pose
toujours un problème ailleurs aux états
unis vous pouvez avoir de vie pouvait
passer de la politique ch passer au
journalisme etc
en france et cette idée que cette
révolution culturelle que vous faites et
bien c'est pas possible ce qui est un
soupçon de connivence permanente sur les
journalistes et c'est ainsi il prend son
meilleur son destin en main elles sont
si dire qu'il était si dire il dit un
truc là tout à l'heure et j'ai pas
complètement avec lui c'est vrai que le
fait qu'il soit au rassemblement et
primal peut plus parler que s'il avait
été celle à france insoumise chez les
républicains
ah oui c'est une évidence les amants que
s'il avait rejoint yannick jadot les
verts sur les efforts non parleront
peut-être pas ce soir c'est ça s'est
resserré effectivement alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire est-ce qu'il faut y
voir un signal politique d'une
banalisation d'une dédiabolisation etc
les pas moi je pense que c'est comme ça
aussi que le voit les téléspectateurs
parce que quand on a vu
un garçon pendant 20 ans journaliste sur
lci dont qui connaît les arcanes du
métier qui connaît bien la politique et
qui choisit le rassemblement national on
se dira si vous laissez tomber pour
aller au rassemblement national et les
virois
c'est vraie adhésion des prestations
c'est une vraie adhésion c'est qu'il y
croit vraiment et ça peut ça peut faire
mine de rien ça peut ça peut faire
réfléchir
voilà et c'est vrai que moi c'est ça qui
marine qui m'a un petit peu fait tiquer
je me suis dit c'est quand même hein
c'est un geste fort non mais c'est parce
qu'on sait pas un mec qui vient
d'arriver les journalistes lui six mois
puis dion finalement je peux dire mais
il avait un ton guerrier effectivement
on a longtemps dit que les électeurs du
front national c'est c'était un vote de
refus c'est à dire tes potes d'adhésion
mais c'était un vote de refus
or là c'est un journaliste politique
féru de politique il connaît les arcanes
et c est donc on imagine qu'il a
réfléchi que s'est posée et que 7,7
c'est une vraie adhésion pour le coup et
ça participe de la dédiabolisation de ce
parti là guillaume on se dit que ce
monsieur qui nous a présenté des
émissions d'information pendant des
années qui a animé des débats qui a mené
des interviews politiques à une opinion
politique est très marqué puisqu'il est
membre et donc électeurs j'imagine du
rassemblement national et pour moi ya
une vraie différence entre avoir un
regard sur l'actualité comme sonia
mabrouk comme parce qu'elle prouve
combien de voir et être adhérent
officiellement d'un parti c'est
compliqué pour la suite l'a apparemment
il a quand même continué d'officiels
antenne en ayant sa carte mais c'est
compliqué pour le passé chevaux 6 alors
les débats étaient orientés on va pas on
va passer mais tous les jours n'est
normalement pas parce qu'on l'a t on à
l'interview excuses mais on sait qu'elle
a une sensibilité malouche - le nom mais
léa salamé et déjà elle est sur france
inter bah oui entre déjà synthèse déjà
oui mais là il faut arrêter les mots
il faut arrêter l'hypocrisie quand même
bon là il a dit qu'il est hors assemblée
comme ça suit serre mais il est sain il
à doha de le faire il ya tellement de
journalistes il suffit de les écouter on
imagine pour qui ils votent donc
arrêtons l'hypocrisie est une chose et
c'est autre chose mais être encarté
appartement on est encarté là et c'est
ce qui m'a fait d'ailleurs même s'il a
mis un petit peu de temps à le faire
malheureusement ce que j'aurais préféré
qu'ils quittent d'abord son métier
journalistes pour ensuite être écartée
c'est ça qui pose question à mon sens
mais appartement où il est encarté un
journaliste doit quitter sa fonction
c'est parce qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
nous qui est un des visages connus dans
l'immédiat puisque vous étiez
chroniqueur aux grandes gueules vous
êtes venu nous voir ici vous est ce que
ça vous choque qu'un présentateur de
chaînes info s'engage en politique
non moi ça me choque pas qu'ils
s'engagent en politique le problème j'ai
un désaccord avec valérie c'est que
justement pour moi c'est tous les autres
journalistes qui font du bluff de sous
prétexte de ne pas être organisée de
faire semblant qu'ils sont pas militants
militants politiques
sonia mabrouk elle est militante
politique en réalité pas organiser mais
les militants politiques
lorsque par exemple l attaque la
présidente de l'unef et que derrière ce
quelques semaines après il ya un
amendement à l'assemblée nationale quand
même un amendement appelé amendement
unef par rapport à la question de la non
mixité
ça c'est ça c'est quoi si c'est pas du
journalisme politique et si c'est pas
une orientation
lorsqu'on à louis de raguenel qui est le
ciel le chef service politique qui vient
de valeurs actuelles et qui était chef
du service politique de l'ump
qu'est ce que c'est en fait de faire
croire que ces gens là viennent faire de
manière impartiale en fait de la
politique moi j'étais aux grandes
gueules plus de 20 mois où je vous dit
que vous avez été viré à cause de vos
idées c'est vrai ça oui travers madiana
5,13 à leur échapper les seules données
soit vous arrêtez vous avez peut-être la
direction aller chez le dos laissant
vous donnez votre version enfin moi très
clairement olivier truchot m'appelle
vendredi j'étais prévu le lundi m'a
appelé vendredi à 19 heures il m'a dit
on a fait un peu de blabla cinq minutes
et puis après derrière m'a dit que je
dois annoncer que on s'arrête là la prod
ne veut plus ne veut plus on a essayé de
bataille etc etc
moi j'étais prévu c'était premier jour
de confier je suis très serein c'est à
dire que moi moi pour moi quand je suis
arrivé aux grandes gueules et quand je
viens dans les télés c'est la première
et dernière fois ses deux matches est là
et l'invoquer raison olivet toujours
plusieurs îles en ville
invoquer la question militante c'est à
dire que quand un as quasi pied
militants et je les ai toujours dit
c'est-à-dire que moi je suis militant
syndical et politique au npa
bien avant d'arriver aux grandes gueules
mais bon je vois la directrice de la
prod elle elle fait elle me demande mon
cv m 10 elle essaye de savoir mon
parcours donc le les grandes gueules
savait qui j'étais ce que je faisais
savez que je suis cheminot je travaille
au triage du bourget je suis engagé et
le moment de la réforme des retraites en
fait avec le niveau d'intensité qu'il y
avait ça a pesé aussi sur le savez dans
les lignes est jugé très bien terminé
mais après je me remets mon propos sinon
c'est le matelas par les télés real
ramon desquels les raisons pour
lesquelles c'est que le militantisme de
gauche ou d'extrême gauche celui qui
vise à défendre les prolétaires les
petites gens et cetera on ne veut pas
par contre quand goldnadel il dit sur
mon honneur aux grandes gueules il dit
sur mon honneur je serai l'avocat de
génération identitaire quand il est sur
ces news qui dit c'est pas la même chose
sur les questions de pédophilie je vais
pas redire toute la phrase quand barbara
lefebvre elle dit sur lci
concernant l'euthanasie il faut jeter au
dessus d'un pont y a personne qui leur
demandent la moindre chose moi j'ai fait
deux mois de grève 64 jours de grève
j'ai dit aux grandes gueules et je suis
venu chez toi cyril a bien aux tons
parce qu'on avait interpellé djebbari
j'aurais dis moi les gars je vous laisse
payer pendant les grandes gueules je
viens pas moins chiant grève choc aux
côtés de mes collègues disent que je
viens pas aux grandes gueules et on m'a
reproché en fait on m'a demandé de
rendre des comptes pourquoi tu fais
grève et pourquoi tu menaces et pourquoi
pas si on va boire un soda jeu si vous
permettez d'abord vous n'avez pas le
monopole de la défense des gens modestes
et fort heureusement dans ce pays
deuxième chose je ne suis pas une
militante politique j'aimerais revenir
sur l'exemple que vous avez
effectivement cité qu'est la présente de
l'unef quand on fait une interview que
ce soit une personnalité de droite de
gauche de la cité civile notre objectif
est il n'est pas caché c'est de susciter
le débat politique c'est que ce soit qui
ait amendements mais qu'il est quelque
chose qui bouge dans le débat politique
donc c'est sa fête l'ambiance a rien su
c'est de terminer avec bruno le maire
terminée
terminer à l'as fait l'interview
terminée sur niort je viendrai
interviewer si c'est votre objectif est
passé de l'autre côté de la barrière je
suis sûr que vous mènerez des matériaux
exceptionnel j'ai pas fait aucun doute
là dessus et pour la presse c'est un peu
ironique vous l'aurez compris pour la
présidente de l'unef déplore la
présidente dernière c'était un droit de
réponse
si tu as une interview que j'avais
effectué de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur elle est venue
à la radio et moi ce qui m'a choqué vous
voyez c'est de dire qu'en france il ya
des réunions non mixité raciale
c'est à dire qu'en france que pour
rassembler chaque jour lutter contre les
discriminations
je suis sûr qu'on peut se rassembler sur
ce point parce qu'il ya des
discriminations contre lesquels il faut
évidemment lutter et combattre cela sert
alors jeudi sony risque les romains jeu
j'ai une chance aux réunions anti blanc
pour rassembler pour lutter contre la
discrimination il faut rassembler pas
exclure c'est simplement alors si vous
considérez pas cela l'art serbe cela
monsieur c'était le minimum alors je
suis sur le mont billy d'entre elles en
fait et discutant tracy midland victimes
de discrimination et il est temps pour
la france c'est ça qui vous échappe
malheureusement et sa valorisation
ça fait dix ans qu'est ce que je vais
dire d'ailleurs je pense que ça veut
dire mais c'est une certaine idée de la
france et est vrai que c'est une idée où
nous avons une thèse et une non pas une
idée en fait c'est une sorte d'idéal
universaliste fait sourire monsieur moi
cette saison des lignes et de ses
ministres ce que vous avez parlé des
femmes
je pourrais citer puisqu'elle est franco
tunisienne disait la limite serra qui
tout simplement depuis toujours depuis
leur combat savent que pour lutter
contre les discriminations qui sont
faites contre les femmes
ils sont faites contre les minorités on
ne peut pas se dire qu'on se rassemble
entre nous pour lutter contre cela
c'était facile vous faire arrêter mais
si c'est ça se réunir en eau mixité
raciale s'est passé dire pardonnez moi
c'est m au bord de la porte moi qui suis
ni lin cette pente mais léo déchirante
moi je suis syndicales et je me réveille
majorité doit lui aussi c'est le patron
d'en donner à ma vous n'avez pas
vraiment mais c'est juste c'est quoi
votre version de le feu pourquoi il a
été écarté un apple moi c'est pas mal de
gens à la radio qui tue donc une radio
privée et donc vous avez appelé
plusieurs fois la révolution à
l'insurrection
c'est ce alors voilà et aussi vous avez
été impliqué dans une action violente
d'intrusion à la cfdt me semble-t-il pas
de tout
ou forcément bains jean la rédaction au
sein de la direction ça va pas faire
plus explicite sur mon compte twitter et
écrit je suis marxiste donc les marques
c'est c'ui de base ils sont plus
question donc c'est qu'ils sont assez
faux c'est à dire que toutes les fois il
n'y a pas eu un dérapage dans les
grandes gueules l'action de la cfdt je
suis venu ici et c'était face à claire
o'petit au moment où il y avait même le
théâtre des bouffes du nord
on est rentré dans la cfdt parce qu'on
disait au moment de la réforme des
retraites pendant que laurent berger il
était en train de négocier la régression
sociale on a dit on n'a pas besoin de
berger dans cette grève parce qu'à pas
de moutons c'était ça notre slogan on
est venu à la cfdt en est ressorti il ya
une plainte il ya personne qui est parti
né en garde à vue ni quoi que ce soit ni
aucune condamnation mon visage il est
connu il ya si j'avais eu des problèmes
c'est pas ça le souci le vrai souci
c'est que les périodes qui sont envahis
à béziers si tu te rappelles s'ils ont
leur absolue même le car régie et
lorsque eric brunet au moment où il
était encore rmc il m'appelle et me
demandent en fait de prendre position
pour les grandes gueules contre des
grévistes
au moment de la réforme des retraites
j'ai dit non moi je je je je je je je
vais pas à l'encontre en fait d'aider de
mes idées c'est à dire celles qui visent
à lutter pour les droits des salariés
des travailleurs et des petites erreurs
mais j'ai toujours été comme ça c'est
comme ça que j'ai été
ils ont rigolé même vous comprenez aussi
que la somme n'est que j'ai une gueule
après c'était compliqué aussi n'ont pas
nécessairement oublier qu'un droit que
gilles william goldnadel il dit ils
défendent dans les débats sont pas dans
les grandes gares l'état aujourd'hui en
public puisque vote mais ça nous est
revisité les biens pas dire que la
liberté doit pas humilier en public
c'est laurent ruquier et tous les autres
pensées qui font une pause une une
comment dire du journalisme du service
public ou est ce que quand vous regardez
dans la liste des chaires dans
l'ensemble des chaînes excusez moi mais
ont gardé les jours à risque ce sont les
personnes essayent de la classe d'objets
de néons des invités nous avons quatre
sites et nous les journalistes il n'y a
pas que une forme d'économie sme c'était
un final à un économisme de gauche
d'extrême gauche et sera absent des
terrains un journaliste est à votre bras
et s'avoue fan astucieux qui se classe à
tes yeux du moins oui voila j'ai la
vérité moi c'est pas une histoire de
grâce à mes yeux si rip faut comprendre
moi j'ai pas de problème de discuter des
genres à exorbitants avec gilles william
goldnadel ou avec isabelle saporta
mais on peut pas dire un as toi tes
militants et pas dire à isabelle saporta
que c'est la femme de jade goody 2
de poids donc on peut pas dire à un
aspect militant et laure habitants qui
était chef de la communication des
manuels valsecchi et eva green se
débattre avec avaya pas de problème j'ai
débattu plein de fois avec goldnadel
j'ai débattu plein mercato mi-temps
plateau quel journaliste a grâce à vos
yeux
il ya des journalistes de gauche a déjà
en éclats des journées les biens des
journalises reporter les serrures qui
font du travail j'apprécie le jour n'est
ce qu'il ya chez certains dans
libération à mediapart et ses médias
malraux il ya des médias indépendants le
rayon de positionnement en parler c'est
pas la femme de pardonner mais d'abord
ils appellent ça va comme ça c'est
d'abord la maison me rappelais ci
travaillait avant il avait qu'a passé
lyon la ville de janot ouais mais bon on
n'a qu'un débat la mèche que donc pour
vous la jeune femme d'un représentant
politique d'europe écologie les verts
qui dit elle même qu'elle défend la
candidature de son mari qu'elle défend
la candidature c'est mal je sur place
des normes européennes
elle attend la seconde elle appartient
depuis le nord est fort heureusement
al-hassaba vous n'avez pas besoin de
parler en son nom et en a pas je me
parle en son nom de son mari ni de son
compagnon en vélo j'aimerais isabelle
saporta journalistes bien avant d'être
avec annie genou et fait contrer si on
plaît